let's go next to our caller from the
seven six zero area code who's calling
today from seven six zero I think yes it
is alright I can barely hear you it
sounds like you're sort of underwater
are you using a Bluetooth headset right
now no can hear me better now David yes
I can okay hi my name's Marshall
informal window for did you get that yes
I did okay so I'm doing a bit of an
academic project I consider myself an
Objectivist and so I'm kind of trying to
get the best critique of Objectivism
that are out there I know obviously you
probably somebody who doesn't agree with
obsessive ism you know that you know the
Radian variety i've been trying to scour
the internet looking for like the best
like you know systematic academic based
takedowns of her philosophy have you
seen anything you want me to the best
actual critique instead of like not ad
hominem attack on her character or
half-baked attempts you know i've not
deep dive into critiques of Objectivism
so i mean III would be sure if you were
to google and including if you go to
Google Scholar and search for critiques
of Objectivism I'd be shocked if it was
at homonyms about eine Ram right right
so I it's mainly like the Internet
article they should avoid like you know
like new that journal journals and or
major news websites and stuff like that
like actually look for academic critique
well if you're you said you were looking
for an academic critique so if that's
the case I would look on Google Scholar
Google Scholar okay alright thank you
for the call Marshall appreciate it